well you do happen to be working on a
thing which seems to have a potentially
some of the greatest impact on human
civilization of anything humans have
ever created which is artificial
intelligence this is on the both
detailed technical level and in a high
philosophical level you work on so
you've mentioned to me that there's an
open letter
that you're working on it's actually uh
going live in a few hours so I've been
having late nights and early mornings
it's been very exciting actually I in
short
I have you seen uh don't look up
the film
yes yes I don't want to be the movie
spoiler for anyone watching this who
hasn't seen it but if you're watching
this you haven't seen it watch it
because we are actually acting out it's
it's life imitating art humanity is
doing exactly that right now except
it's an asteroid that we are building
ourselves
almost nobody is talking about it
people are squabbling across the planet
about all sorts of things which seem
very minor compared to the asteroid
that's about to hit us right
most politicians don't even have their
radar this on the radar they think maybe
in 100 years or whatever
right now we're at a fork on the road
this is the most important Fork the
humanity has reached and it's over a
hundred thousand years on this planet
we're building
effectively a new species that's smarter
than us
it doesn't look so much like a species
yet because it's mostly not embodied in
robots but um
that's the technicality which will soon
be changed and and this arrival of
artificial general intelligence they can
do all our jobs as well as us and
probably shortly thereafter super
intelligence which greatly exceeds our
cognitive abilities it's going to either
be the the best thing ever to happen
Humanity or the worst I'm really quite
confident that there is
not that much Middle Ground there but it
would be fundamentally transformative
to human civilization of course utterly
and totally you know
again we branded ourselves as Homo
sapiens because it seemed like the basic
thing where the King of the castle on
this planet were the Smart Ones if we
can control everything else
this could very easily change we're
certainly not going to be the smartest
on the planet for very long if AI unless
AI progress just Falls and we can talk
more about why I I think that's true
because it's it's controversial
and and then we can also talk about
reasons you might think it's gonna be
the best thing ever and the reason you
think it's going to be the end of
humanity
which is of course super controversial
but
what I think we can anyone who's working
on uh Advanced AI
can agree on is it's it's much like the
film don't look up and that
it's just really comical how little
serious public debate there is about it
given how huge it is
so what we're talking about is the
development of currently things like
gpt4
and the signs it's showing of uh rapid
Improvement that may in the near term
lead to development of super intelligent
AGI AI General AI systems and what kind
of impact that has on society exactly
when that thing is achieves General
human level intelligence and then beyond
that
General superhuman level intelligence
there's a lot of questions to explore
here so one you mentioned halt
is that uh the content of the letter is
to suggest that maybe we should pause
the development of these systems exactly
so this is very controversial
from when we talked the first time we
talked about how I was involved in
starting the future Life Institute and
we worked very hard on 2014 2015 was the
mainstream AI safety
the idea that there even could be risks
and that you could do things about them
before then a lot of people thought it
was just really kooky to even talk about
it and a lot of AI researchers felt
worried that this was too flaky and
could be bad for funding and that the
people had talked about it were just
just not didn't understand AI
I'm very very happy with
how that's gone in the now you know it's
completely mainstream you go on any AI
conference and people talk about AI
safety and it's a nerdy technical field
full of equations and simula and blah
blah
um
as it should be
but there's this other thing which has
been quite taboo up until now
calling for slowdown so what
we've been constantly been saying
including myself I've been biting my
tongue a lot you know is that you know
we we don't need to slow down AI
development we just need to win this
race the wisdom race between the growing
power of the AI
and the growing wisdom with which we
manage it and rather than trying to slow
down AI let's just try to accelerate the
wisdom do all this technical work to
figure out how you can actually ensure
that your powerful AI is going to do
what you wanted to do and have Society
adapt also
with um incentives and regulations so
that these things get put to good use
um sadly that
didn't pan out
the progress on technical Ai and
capabilities has gone
a lot faster than than many people
thought
back when we started this in 2014 turned
out to be easier to build really nice AI
than we thought
um
and uh on the other side it's gone much
slower than we hoped with getting um
policy makers and others to actually
put the incentives in place to to make
steer this in the in good directions we
can maybe we should unpack it and talk a
little bit about each so yeah why did it
go faster than we then a lot of people
thought them
in hindsight it's exactly like building
um
flying machines
people spent a lot of time wondering
about how how do birds fly you know and
that turned out to be really hard have
you seen the Ted talk with a flying bird
like a flying robotic Bird yeah it flies
around the audience but it took a
hundred years longer to figure out how
to do that than for the Wright brothers
to build the first airplane because it
turned out there was a much easier way
to fly yeah and evolution picked a more
complicated one because it had its hands
tied it could only build a machine that
could assemble itself
which the Wright brothers didn't care
about they can only build a machine
they'll use only the most common atoms
in the periodic table
Wright brothers didn't care about that
they could use steel
iron atoms and it had to be able to
repair itself and it also had to be
incredibly fuel efficient you know
a lot of birds use less than half the
fuel of a remote control plane and
flying the same distance
for humans stroller moment put a little
more fuel in a roof there you go 100
years earlier that's exactly what's
happening now with these large language
models
the brain is incredibly complicated
many people made the mistake you're
thinking we have to figure out how the
brain does human level AI first before
we could build in the machine
that was completely wrong you can take
an incredibly simple
computational system called the
Transformer Network and just train it to
do something incredibly dumb
just read a gigantic amount of text and
try to predict the next word
and it turns out
if you just throw a ton of compute at
that and a ton of data it gets to be
frighteningly good like gpt4 which I've
been playing with so much since it came
out right
and um
there's still some debate about whether
that can get you all the way to full
human level or not
but yeah we can come back to the details
of that and how you might get the human
level AI even if
large language models don't
can you briefly if it's just a small
tangent comment on your feelings about
gpt4 suggest that you're impressed by
this rate of progress but where where is
it can gpt4 reason
what are like the intuitions what are
human interpretable words you can assign
to the capabilities of gpt4 that makes
you so damn impressed with it I'm both
very excited about it I'm terrified
it's interesting mixture of emotions all
the best things in life include those
two somehow
yeah I can absolutely reason anyone who
hasn't played with it I highly recommend
doing that before dissing it
it can do quite quite remarkable
reasoning
I've had to do a lot of things which I
realized I couldn't do that myself that
well even and
and it obviously does it dramatically
faster than we do too when you watch a
type and it's it's doing that while
servicing a massive number of other
humans at the same time at the same time
it cannot reason
as well as a human can on some tasks
just because it's obviously the
limitation from its architecture you
know we have in our heads what in
geekspeak is called the recurrent neural
network there are Loops information can
go from this neuron to this neuron to
this neuron and then back to this one
you can like ruminate on something for a
while you can self-reflect a lot
these large language models that are
they cannot like gpt4 it's it's a
so-called Transformer where it's just
like a one-way Street of information
basically and geek speak it's called the
feed forward neural network
and it's only so deep
so it can only do logic that's that many
steps and that deep and it's not
and you can so you can create problems
which will fail to solve you know for
that reason
um
but the fact that it can do so amazing
things with this incredibly simple
architecture already it's quite stunning
and and what we see in my lab at MIT
when we look inside
large language models to try to figure
out how they're doing it that's the key
core focus of
our research it's called um mechanistic
interpretability in geek speak you know
you have this machine it does something
smart you try to reverse reverse
engineer see how does it do it
and think of it also as artificial
Neuroscience that's exactly what
neuroscientists do with actual brains
but here you have the advantage that you
can you don't have to worry about
measurement errors you can see what
every neuron is doing all the time and
and a recurrent thing we see again and
again
there's been a number of beautiful
papers quite recently by
by a lot of researchers some of them
here I am in this area is where when
they figure out how something is done
he said oh man that's such a dumb way of
doing it and you immediately see how it
can be improved like for example
there was a beautiful paper recently
where they figured out how a large
language model stores certain facts like
Eiffel Tower is in Paris
and they figured out exactly how it's
stored and where the proof that they
understood it was they could edit it
they changed some of the synapses in it
and then they asked it where's the
Eiffel Tower and I said it's in Rome and
then they asked you know how do you get
there oh how do you get there from
Germany oh you take this train and to
Roma Termini train station and this and
that and what might you see if you're in
front of it oh you might see the
Coliseum so they had edit it so they
literally moved it to Rome but it the
way it's storing this information it's
incredibly dumb for for any fellow nerds
listening to this there was a big Matrix
and a
and roughly speaking there are certain
row and column vectors which encode
these things and they correspond very
kindly to principal components and it
would be much more efficient for sparse
Matrix just store it in the database you
know and but and everything so far we've
figured out how these things do our ways
where you can see they can easily be
improved and the fact that this
particular architecture has some
roadblocks built into it is in no way
going to prevent um
craft the researchers from quickly
finding workarounds and making
other kinds of architectures
sort of go all the way so so it's um in
short it's turned out to be a lot
easier to build human close to human
intelligence than we thought and that
means our Runway is a species that
get our together has shortened
and it seems like the scary thing about
the effectiveness of large language
models so Sam Altman understand a
conversation with
and
he really showed that the leap from gpt3
to gpt4 has to do with just a bunch of
hacks
a bunch of
little Explorations about with the smart
researchers doing a few little fixes
here and there it's not some fundamental
leap and transformation in the
architecture and more data and more
compute and more data compute but he
said the big leaps has to do with not
the data in the compute but just
learning this new discipline just like
you said so researchers are going to
look at these architectures and there
might be big leaps where you realize
wait why are we doing this in this dumb
way yeah and all of a sudden this model
is 10x smarter yeah and that that can
happen on any one day on anyone Tuesday
or Wednesday afternoon and then all of a
sudden you have a system that's 10x
smarter
um it seems like it's such a new
discipline it's such a new like we
understand so little about why this
thing works so damn well that uh the
linear Improvement of compute or
exponential but the steady Improvement
of compute steady Improvement of the
data may not be the thing that even
leads to the next leap it could be a
surprise little hack that improves
everything for a lot of little leaps
here and there because
because so much of this is out in the
open also
so many smart people are looking at this
and trying to figure out little leaps
here and there and uh it becomes this
sort of collective race where if a lot
of people feel if I don't take the leap
someone else will and this is actually
very crucial for for the other part of
it why do we want to slow this down so
again what this open letter is calling
for is just pausing
all training
of uh
systems that are more powerful than gpt4
for six months
give a chance
for the labs to coordinate a bit on
safety and for societies adapt give the
right incentives to the labs because I
you know you've interviewed a lot of
these
people who lead these labs and you know
just as well as I do they're good people
they're idealistic people they're doing
this
first and foremost because they believe
that AI has a huge potential to help
humanity and uh
but at the same time they are trapped in
this
this horrible race to the bottom
have you read meditations on molok
by Scott Alexander yes yeah it's a
beautiful essay on this poem by Ginsburg
where he interprets it as being about
this monster
it's this game theory monster that that
pits people into against each other in
this this race to the bottom where
everybody ultimately loses the edit the
evil thing about this monster is even
though everybody sees it and understands
they still can't get out of the race
right
most a good fraction of all the bad
things that we humans do are caused by
moloch and I like uh Scott Alexander's
um
naming of the monster so we can we
humans can think of it as an a thing
if you look at why do we have
overfishing why do we have more
generally like tragedy of the commons
why is it that um
I don't know if you've had her on your
podcast yeah she's become a friend yeah
great she made this awesome point
recently that beauty filters that a lot
of female
influencers feel pressured to use or
exactly malloc in action again first
nobody was using them
and people saw them just the way they
were and then some of them started using
it
I'm becoming ever more Plastic Fantastic
and then the other ones that weren't
using it started to realize that
if they want to just keep their their
market share they have to start using it
too
and that and then you're in a situation
where they're all using it and and none
of them has any more market share or
less than before so
nobody gained anything everybody lost
and they have to keep becoming ever more
Plastic Fantastic also right
and uh
but nobody can go back to the old way
because it's just
too costly right Morlock is everywhere
and um
molok is not a new arrival on on the
scene either we humans have developed a
lot of collaboration mechanisms to help
us fight back against Malik through
various kinds of constructive
collaboration the Soviet Union and the
United States did sign the number of our
Arms Control treaties
against moloch who is trying to stoke
them into
unnecessarily risky nuclear arms races
Etc et cetera and this is exactly what's
happening on the AI front this time
it's a little bit geopolitics but it's
mostly money where there's just so much
commercial pressure you know if you take
any of these
leaders of the top tech companies
if they just say you know this is too
risky I want to pause for six months
they're going to get a lot of pressure
from shareholders and others
we're like well you know if you pause
but those guys don't pause
we're if you don't want to get our lunch
eaten yeah and shareholders even have a
power to replace the the executives in
the worst case right so
we did this open letter because we want
to help these idealistic Tech Executives
to do
what their heart tells them by providing
enough public pressure on the whole
sector just pause so that they can all
pause
in a coordinated fashion and I think
without the public pressure none of them
can do it alone
push back against their shareholders no
matter how good-hearted they are smaller
is a really powerful foe
so the idea is to
for the major developers of AI systems
like this so we're talking about
Microsoft Google
meta
and anyone else open AI is very close
with Microsoft and there are plenty of
smaller players and throw for example
anthropic which is very impressive
there's conjecture there's many many
many players that I want to make a long
list so leave anyone out and
um
for that reason it's so important that
some coordination happens that there's
external pressure on all of them saying
you all need the pawns because then the
the people the researchers in they were
these organizations the leaders who want
to slow down a little bit they can say
they're shareholders you know
everybody's slowing down because of this
pressure and and it's the right thing to
do
have you seen in history their uh
examples where it's possible to pause
them all up absolutely
and even like human cloning for example
you could make so much money on human
cloning
uh
why aren't we doing it
because biologists thought hard about
this and found like this is way too
risky we they got together well in the
70s in the cinema and decided even
to stop a lot more stuff also just
editing the human germline right
Gene editing that goes in
to our offspring
and decided let's let's not do this
because it's too unpredictable what it's
going to lead to
we could lose control over what happens
to our species so they paused
there was a ton of money to be made
there so it's it's very doable but you
just need you need a public awareness of
the of what the risks are and the
broader Community coming in and saying
hey let's slow down and you know another
another common pushback I get today is
we We Can't Stop In The West
because China
and in China undoubtedly they also get
told we can't slow down because the West
because both sides think they're the
good guy yeah
but look at human cloning you know
did China Forge ahead with human cloning
there's been exactly one human cloning
that's actually been done that I know of
it was done by a Chinese guy do you know
where he is now right in jail
and you know who put him there who
Chinese government
not because westerners said China look
this is no the Chinese government put
him there because they also felt
they like control the Chinese government
if anything maybe they are even more
concerned about having control then the
Western governments have no incentive of
just losing control over where
everything is going
and you can also see the Ernie bot that
was released by I believe Baidu recently
they got a lot of pushback from the
government and had to rein it in you
know in a big way
um
I think once this basic message comes
out that this isn't an arms race it's a
suicide race
where everybody loses if anybody's AI
goes out of control it really changes
the whole dynamic it's not
it's
I'll say this again because this is a
very basic point I think a lot of people
get wrong because a lot of people
dismiss the whole idea that AI can
really get
very superhuman because they think
there's something really magical about
intelligence such that it can only exist
in human Minds you know because they
believe that I think it's going to kind
of get to just more or less
gpd4 plus plus and then that's it
they don't see it as a super as a
suicide race they think whoever gets
that first they're going to control the
world they're going to win but that's
not how it's going to be and we can talk
again about
the the scientific arguments from why
it's not going to stop there but
the way it's going to be is if anybody
completely loses control and you know
you don't care if if
some some if someone manages to take
over the world who really doesn't share
your goals you probably don't really
even care very much about what
nationality they have you're not going
to like it much worse than today
who if it's if you live in orwellian
dystopia who you what do you care who's
created it right and if someone if it
goes farther and and
we just lose control even to the
machines
so that it's not US versus them it's US
versus it
what do you care who who created this
this underlying entity which has goals
different from humans ultimately and we
get marginalized we get made obsolete we
get replaced
um that's why what I mean when I say
it's a suicide race you know it's um
it's kind of like we're rushing towards
this cliff but the closer the cliff we
get the more Scenic the views are and
the more money there is there and the
more so we can keep going
but we have to also stop at some point
right quit while we're ahead
and uh
it's um
it's a suicide race which cannot be won
but the way to really benefit from it is
to continue developing awesome AI a
little bit slower so we make it safe
make sure it does the things that humans
want and create a condition where
everybody wins the technology has shown
us that you know geopolitics and and
politics and generalists not a zero-sum
game at all
so there is some rate of development
that will lead
us as a human species to lose control of
this thing and the hope you have is that
there's some lower level of development
which will not which will not allow us
to lose control this is an interesting
thought you have about losing control so
what if you have somebody if you're
somebody like Sandra pracha or Sam
Altman at the head of a company like
this you're saying if they develop an
AGI they too will lose control of it
so no one person can maintain control no
group of individuals can maintain if
it's if it's created
very very soon and as a big black box
that we don't understand like the large
language models yeah then I'm very
confident they're going to lose control
but this isn't just me saying you know
Sam Altman and then Mr sabis have both
said they themselves acknowledge that
you know there's really great risks with
this and they they want to slow down
once they feel it gets scary
it's but it's clear that they're stuck
in this again molok is forcing them to
go a little faster than they're
comfortable with because of pressure
from just commercial pressures right
to get a bit optimistic here of course
this is a problem that can be ultimately
solved
uh it's just to win this wisdom race
it's clear that what we hope that is
going to happen hasn't happened the the
capability progress has gone faster than
a lot of people thought than and the
part the progress in in the public
sphere of policy making and so on has
gone slower than we thought even the
technical AI safety has gone slower a
lot of the technical Safety Research was
kind of banking on that um
large language models and other poorly
understood systems couldn't get us all
the way but you had to build more of a
kind of intelligence that you could
understand maybe it could prove itself
safe you know things like this and
um
I'm quite confident that this can be
done um so we can reap all the benefits
but we cannot do it
as quickly as uh this is out of control
Express train we're on now is gonna get
the AGI that's why we need a little more
time I feel
is there something to be said well like
Sam Allman talked about which is while
we're in the pre-agi stage to release
often and as transparently as possible
to learn a lot
so as opposed to being extremely
cautious release a lot don't uh don't
invest in a closed development where you
focus on AI safety while is somewhat
dumb
quote unquote
uh release as often as possible and as
you start to see signs of
uh human level intelligence or
superhuman level intelligence then you
put a halt on it well
what a lot of safety researchers have
been saying for many years is the most
dangerous things you can do with an AI
is first of all teach it to write code
yeah because that's the first step
towards recursive self-improvement which
can take it from AGI to much higher
levels
okay oops we've done that
and uh another thing high risk is
connected to the internet Let It Go to
websites download stuff on its own and
talk to people
oops we've done that already you know
Elias yukowski you said you interviewed
him recently right yes so he had this
tweet recently which said
God gave me one of the best laughs in a
while where he's like hey people used to
make fun of me and say you're so stupid
Eliezer because you're saying you're
saying um
you have to worry of obviously
developers once they get to like really
strong AI first thing you're going to do
is like never connect it to the internet
Keep It In The Box yeah where you know
you can really study it if
so he had written it in the like in the
meme form so it's like then yeah and
then that and then now
LOL let's make a chatbot
yeah and the third thing is Stuart
Russell yeah you know
amazing AI researcher he
he has argued for a while that
we should never teach AI anything about
humans
above all we should never let it learn
about human psychology and how you
manipulate humans
that's the most dangerous kind of
knowledge you can give it yeah you can
teach it all it needs to know how about
how to cure cancer and stuff like that
but don't let it read Daniel kahneman's
book about cognitive biases and all that
and then
oops lol you know let's invent social
media
I'll recommender algorithms which do
exactly that they they get so good at
knowing us and pressing our buttons
that we've we're starting to create a
world now where we just have ever more
hatred
because they figured out that these
algorithms not for out of evil but just
to make money on Advertising that the
best way to get more engagement with
euphemism
get people glued to their little
rectangles right it's just to make them
pissed off that's really interesting
that a large AI system that's doing the
recommender system kind of task on
social media is basically just studying
human beings because it's a bunch of us
rats giving it signal
non-stop signal it'll show a thing and
it will give signal on whether we spread
that thing we like that thing that thing
increases our engagement gets us to
return to the platform and it has that
on the scale of hundreds of millions of
people constantly so it's just learning
and learning and learning and presumably
if the param the number of parameters in
the neural network that's doing the
learning and more end to end the
learning is
the more it's able to just basically
encode how to manipulate human behavior
how to control humans at scale exactly
and that is not something you think is
in Humanity's interest
yeah right now it's mainly letting some
humans manipulate other humans for
profit
and Power
which already
caused a lot of damage and eventually
that's a sort of
skill that can make ai's persuade humans
to let them Escape
whatever safety precautions but you know
there was a really nice article um in
the New York Times recently by uh you
all know a Harari and and two co-authors
including Tristan Harris from the social
dilemma and
we have this phrase in there I love it
Humanity's first contact with Advanced
AI
on social media
and we lost that one
we now live in a country where there's
much more hate in the world where
there's much more hate in fact
and in our democracy that we're having
this conversation and people can't even
agree on who won the last election you
know
and we humans often point fingers at
other humans and say it's their fault
but it's really molok and these AI
algorithms
we got the algorithms and then molok
pitted the social media companies are
against each other so nobody could have
a less creepy algorithm because then
they would lose out on our Revenue to
the other company is there any way to
win that battle back just if we just
Linger on this one battle that we've
lost in terms of social media is it
possible to redesign social media this
very medium in which we use as a
civilization to communicate with each
other to have these kinds of
conversations to have discourse to try
to figure out how to solve the biggest
problems in the world whether that's
nuclear war or the development of AGI is
is it possible
uh to do social media correct I think
it's not only possible but it's it's
necessary who are we kidding that we're
going to be able to solve all these
other challenges if we can't even have a
conversation with each other it's
constructive the whole idea the key idea
of democracy is that you get a bunch of
people together
and they have a real conversation the
ones you try to Foster on this podcast
or you respectfully listen to people you
disagree with
and you realize actually you know there
are some things actually we some common
ground we have and that's it's yeah we
both agree let's not have a nuclear Wars
let's not do that
um etc etc
we're kidding ourselves the thinking we
can face off the
second contact with with ever more
powerful AI that's happening now with
these large language models if we can't
even
have a functional
conversation in the public space that's
why I started to improve the news
project improve the news.org but um
I I'm an optimist fundamentally in um
and that there is a lot of intrinsic
goodness
in in people
and that uh what makes the difference
between someone doing good things for
for Humanity and bad things is not
some sort of fairy tale thing that this
person was born with the evil Gene and
this one is not born with a good Gene no
I think it's whether we put whether
people
find themselves in situations that bring
out the best in them or they bring out
the worst in them and I feel we're
building an internet
and a society that brings out the worst
but it doesn't have to be that way no it
does not it's possible to create
incentives and also create incentives
that make money
they both make money and bring out the
best in people I mean in the long term
it's not a good investment for anyone
you know to have a nuclear war for
example
and you know is it a good investment for
Humanity if we just ultimately replace
all humans by machines and then we're so
obsolete that eventually the
there are no humans left
well it depends against how you do the
math but like if I would say by any
reasonable economics started if you look
at the future income of humans and there
aren't any you know that's not a good
investment
moreover like why why can't we have a
little bit of pride in our species damn
it you know why should we just build
another species that gets rid of us if
we were Neanderthals
would we really consider it a smart move
if the
if we had really Advanced biotech to
build homo sapiens
you you know you might say hey Max you
know yeah let's build build the
these Homo sapiens they're going to be
smarter than us maybe they can help us
defend us better against the Predators
and help fix their bar caves make them
nicer and we'll control them undoubtedly
you know so then they build build a
couple a little baby girl little baby
boy you know and
and then you have some some wise old and
Neanderthal Elder was like hmm
I'm scared that uh we're opening a
Pandora's Box here and that we're gonna
get outsmarted by these
super Neanderthal intelligences and
there won't be any neanderthals left and
then but then you have a bunch of others
in the cave are you such a Luddite
scaremonger or of course they're going
to want to keep us around because we are
their creators and and why you know the
smart I think the smarter they get the
nicer they're gonna get they're gonna
leave us they're gonna
they're gonna want this around and it's
going to be fine and and besides look at
these babies they're so cute
it's clearly they're totally harmless
that's exact those babies are exactly
gpt4 yeah it's not I want to be clear
it's not gpt4
that's terrifying it's the gpt4 is a
baby technology
you know at Microsoft even had a paper
recently out
with a title something like sparkles of
AGI whatever basically saying this is
baby AI
like these little Neanderthal babies
and it's gonna grow up there's gonna be
other systems from from the same company
from other companies they'll be way more
powerful and but they're going to take
all the things
ideas from these babies
and before we know it we're gonna be
like
those last neanderthals who are pretty
disappointed and when they realized that
they were getting replaced well this
interesting point you make which is the
programming is it's entirely possible
that GPT 4 is already
the kind of system that can
change everything
by writing programs like three it's yeah
it's because it's Life 2.0
the systems I'm afraid of are going to
look nothing like a large language model
and they're not
but once it gets once it or other people
figure out a way of using this Tech to
make much better Tech right it's just
constantly replacing its software and
from everything we've seen about how how
these work under the hood they're like
the minimum viable intelligence they do
everything you know the dumbest way that
still works sort of yeah and um
so they are life 3.0 except when they
replace their software it's a lot faster
than when you when when you decide to
learn Swedish
and moreover they think a lot faster
than us too so when uh you know
we don't think uh how
one
logical step every nanosecond or a few
or so the way they do and we can't also
just suddenly scale up our Hardware
massively in the cloud because we're so
limited right
so they are and they are also life have
consumed become a little bit more like
life 3.0 and that if they need more
Hardware hey just rent it in the cloud
you know how do you pay for it well with
all the services you provide
and what we haven't seen yet
which could change a lot is uh entire
Software System so right now programming
is done sort of in bits and pieces uh as
as an assistant tool to humans but I do
a lot of programming and with the kind
of stuff that gbt4 is able to do I mean
is replacing a lot what I'm able to do
but I you still need a human in the loop
to kind of manage the design of things
manage like what are the prompts that
generate the kind of stuff to do some
basic adjustment of the codes let's do
some debugging but if it's possible to
add on top of GPT for kind of uh
feedback loop of of a of uh
self-debugging improving the code and
then you launch that system out into the
wild on the internet because everything
is connected and have it do things have
it interact with humans and then get
that feedback now you have this giant
ecosystem yeah of humans it's one of the
things that um yeah Elon Musk recently
sort of tweeted as a case why everyone
needs to pay Seven dollars or whatever
for Twitter to make sure they're real
they're make sure the real word now
going to be living in a world where the
the Bots are getting smarter and smarter
and smarter to a degree where you can't
uh you can't tell the difference between
a human and a bot that's right and now
you can have uh Bots outnumber humans by
yeah one million to one which is why
he's making the case why you have to pay
yeah to prove you're human which is one
of the only mechanisms which is
depressing and I yeah I feel we have to
remember
as individuals we should from time to
time ask ourselves why are we doing what
we're doing right then as a species we
need to do that too
so if we're building as as you say
machines that are outnumbering us
and more and more outsmarting us and and
replacing us on the job market not just
for the dangerous and and boring tasks
but also for writing poems and doing art
and things that a lot of people find
really meaningful you've got to ask
yourself why why are we doing this
uh we are the answer is moloch is
tricking us into doing it
and it's such a clever trick that even
though we see the trick we still have no
choice but to fall for it right
and coming also the thing you said about
you using uh co-pilot AI tools to
program faster how many times what
factor faster would you say your code
now does it go twice as fast or I don't
really
uh because it's a new tool yeah it's I
don't know if speed is significantly
improved
um but it feels like I'm a year away
from being uh five to ten times faster
so if that's typical for programmers
then uh you're already seeing another
kind of self
recursive self-improvement right because
previously uh one like a major
generation of improvement of the code
would happen on the human r d time scale
and now if that's five times shorter
then it's going to take five times less
time than it otherwise would to develop
the next level of these tools and so on
so this these These are the this is
exactly the sort of beginning of an of
an intelligence explosion that can be
humans in the loop a lot in the early
stages and then eventually humans are
needed less and less and the machines
can more kind of go along but you what
you said there is just an exact example
of these sort of things another thing
which which
I was kind of lying on my psychiatrist
imagining I'm on a psychiatrist's couch
here saying what are my fears that
people would do with um AI systems
another
so I mentioned three that I had fears
about many years ago that they would do
namely uh teacher the code uh connected
to the internet then teach it to
manipulate humans a fourth one is
building an API
where code can control all the super
powerful thing right that's very
unfortunate because one thing that
systems like gpt4 have going for them is
that they are an Oracle in the sense
that they just answer questions there's
no robot connected to the gpt4 gpt4
can't go and do stock trading based on
its thinking yeah it's not an agent an
intelligent agent is something that
takes in information from the world
processes it
to figure out what action to take based
on its goals that it has and then
does something
back on the world but once you have an
API for example gpd4 Nothing Stops Joe
Schmo and all and a lot of other people
from building real agents
which just keep making calls somewhere
in some inner Loops somewhere to these
powerful Oracle systems
and which makes them themselves much
more powerful that's another kind of um
unfortunate development which I think we
would have been better off uh delaying I
don't want to pick on any particular
companies I think they're all under a
lot of pressure to make money yeah
and um
again we the reason we're calling for
this pause is to give them all cover to
do what they know is the right thing
slow down a little bit at this point but
everything we've talked about I hope
will can will make it clear to people
watching this you know why
these sort of human level tools can
cause a gradual acceleration you keep
using yesterday's technology to build
tomorrow's technology yeah and when you
do
that over and over again you naturally
get an explosion you know that's the
definition of an explosion in science
right like
if you have
two people
um they fall in love now you have four
people and then they can make more
babies and now you have eight people and
then then you have 16 32 64 Etc that's
we call that a population explosion
where it's just that each
if it's instead free neutrons in a
nuclear reaction that if H1 can make
more than one then you get an
exponential growth in that we call it a
nuclear explosion all explosions are
like that and an intelligence explosion
it's just exactly the same principle
that some quantity some amount of
intelligence can make more intelligence
than that and then repeat you always get
exponentials
what's your intuition why does you
mentioned there's some technical reasons
why it doesn't stop at a certain point
what's your intuition and uh do you have
any intuition why it might stop
it's obviously going to stop when it
bumps up against the laws of physics
there are some things you just can't do
no matter how smart you are right
allegedly
um
laws of physics yeah yeah right Seth
Lloyd wrote a really cool paper on the
physical limits on uh computation for
example if you make it
put too much energy into it and finite
space it'll turn into a black hole you
can't move information around faster
than the speed of light stuff like that
but uh it's hard to store
way more than than a modest number bits
per atom Etc but you know those limits
are just astronomically above like 30
orders of magnitude above where we are
now so no
bigger different bigger jump in
intelligence than if you go from uh from
an ant to a human
I think
of course what we want to do is have
have a controlled
thing the nuclear reactor you put
moderators in to make sure exactly it
doesn't blow up out of control right
when we do um
experiments with Biology and cells and
so on you know we also try to make sure
it doesn't get out of control
um
we can do this with ai2 the thing is we
haven't succeeded yet and Morlock is
exactly
doing the opposite just fueling just
egging everybody on faster faster faster
or the other company is going to catch
up with you or the other country is
going to catch up with you
we do this we have to want this stuff we
have and and I don't believe in this
just asking people to look into their
hearts and do the right thing it's
easier for others to say that but like
if if you're in a situation where your
company is going to get
screwed
if you
by other companies they're not stopping
you know you're putting people in a very
hard situation the the right thing to do
is change the whole incentive structure
instead
and and this is not an old
maybe I should say one more thing about
this because molok has been around as
Humanity's
number one or number two enemy since the
beginning of civilization and we came up
with some really cool counter measures
like first of all already over a hundred
thousand years ago Evolution realized
that it was very unhelpful that people
kept killing each other all the time
yeah so it genetically
gave us compassion
and made it so that it like if you get
two drunk dudes getting into a pointless
bar fight
they might give each other black eyes
but they have a lot of inhibition
towards towards just killing each other
that's a gen and similarly if you find a
baby lying on the street when you go out
for your morning jog tomorrow you're
gonna stop and pick it up right even
though maybe it make you late for your
next podcast so Evolution gave us these
genes that make our own egoistic
incentives more aligned with what's good
for the greater group or part of right
and then uh as we got a bit more
sophisticated and developed language
we invented gossip which is also a
fantastic anti-malark right because now
it it really discourages
Liars Moochers cheaters because it their
own incentive now is not to do this
because word quickly gets around and
then suddenly people aren't going to
invite them to their dinners anymore or
trust them
and then when we got still more
sophisticated and bigger societies you
know invented the legal system where
even strangers who didn't couldn't rely
on gossip and and things like this would
treat each other would have an incentive
now those guys in the bar fight even if
they someone is so drunk that I
actually wants to kill the other guy
he also has a little thought on the back
of his head that you know do I really
want to spend the next 10 years
eating like really crappy food in a
small room uh I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna chill out you know so and we we
similarly have tried to give these
incentives to our corporations by having
having regulation and all sorts of
oversight so that their incentives are
aligned with the greater good we've
tried really hard
um and um the the big problem that we're
failing now
is not that we haven't tried before but
it's just that the tech is growing much
is developing much faster than the
regulator has been able to keep up right
so
Regulators it's kind of comical the
European Union right now is doing this
AI Act Right which and in the beginning
they had a little opt-out exception that
gpt4 would be completely excluded from
regulation
brilliant idea what's the logic behind
that
some lobbyists pushed successfully for
this so we were actually quite involved
with the future Life Institute
um Mark Bracco Mr ook Anthony Geary and
others you know we're quite involved
with um talking to very educating
various people involved in this process
about
these general purpose AI models coming
and pointing out that they would become
the laughing stock if they didn't put it
in so it the French started pushing for
it it got put in to the draft and it
looked like all was good and then there
was a huge counter push from lobbyists
yeah there were more lobbyists in
Brussels from tech companies and from
oil companies for example and it looked
like it might it's going to maybe get
taken out again
and now gpt4 happened
and I think it's going to stay in but
this just shows you know monologue can
be defeated
but the the challenge we're facing is
that the tech is generally much faster
than what the
policymakers are
and a lot of the policy makers also
don't have a tech background so it's you
know we really need to work hard to
educate them on on how on what's taking
place here
so so we're getting the situation where
the first kind of non so you know I
Define artificial intelligence just as
non-biological intelligence right
and by that definition
a company a corporation is also an
artificial intelligence because the
corporation isn't it's humans it's the
system
if its CEO decides the CEO of a tobacco
company decides one morning that she or
he doesn't want to sell cigarettes
anymore they'll just put another CEO in
there
it's not enough to align the incentives
of individual people or in align
individual computers incentives to their
owners which is what technically AI
Safety Research is about you also have
to align the incentives of Corporations
with a greater good and some
corporations have gotten so big and so
powerful very quickly and that in many
cases they're lobbyists instead align
The Regulators to what they want rather
than the other way around the classic
regulatory capture right is is uh the
thing that the Slowdown hopes to achieve
is give enough time to the regulars to
catch up or enough time to the companies
themselves to breathe and understand how
to do AI safety correctly I think both
and but I think that the vision the path
to success I see is first you give a
breather actually to to the people in
these companies their leadership who
wants to do the right thing and they all
have safety teams and so on other
companies give them a chance to
get together with the other companies
and the outside pressure can also help
catalyze that right
and and work out
what is it that's
what are the reasonable safety
requirements one should put on future
systems before they get rolled out
there are a lot of people also in
Academia and elsewhere outside of these
companies who can be brought into this
and have a lot of very good ideas
and then um
I think it's very realistic that within
six months
you can get these people coming up so
here's a white paper here's where we all
think it's reasonable
um you know you didn't just because cars
killed a lot of people who didn't ban
cars but they got together a bunch of
people and decided you know in order to
be allowed to sell a car it has to have
a seat belt in them
they're the analogous things that you
can start requiring a future AI systems
so that they are are safe
and uh once this have this heavy lifting
this intellectual work has been done by
experts in the field which can be done
quickly
I think it's beginning to be quite easy
to get policy makers to
to see yeah this is a good idea and it's
it's you know
for the fight for the companies to fight
molok
they want and I I believe Sam Altman has
explicitly called for this they want The
Regulators to actually adopt it so that
their competition is going to abide by
it too right you don't want
uh
you don't want to be enacting all these
principles then you abide by them and
then there's this one little
company that
doesn't sign on to it and then now they
can gradually overtake you then the
companies will get
be able to sleep it's secure knowing
that everybody's playing by the same
rules so do you think it's possible to
develop guard rails
that keep the systems from
uh from basically damaging irreparably
Humanity while still enabling sort of
the capitalist fueled competition
between companies as they develop how to
best make money with this AI you think
there's a balancing totally that's
possible absolutely I mean we've seen
them in many other sectors where you've
had the free market produce quite good
things without uh causing particular
harm
um when the guardrails are there and
they work
you know
capitalism is a very effective good way
of optimizing for just getting the same
things done more efficiently it was but
it was good you know then like in
hindsight I never met anyone
even
on parties way over on the right in in
any country who think it was a bad
thinks it was a terrible idea to ban
child labor for example so
yeah but it seems like this particular
technology has gotten so good so fast
become
powerful
to a degree where you could see in the
near term the ability to make a lot of
money and to put guard rails develop
guard rails quickly in that kind of
contact seems to be tricky it's not uh
similar to cars or child labor it seems
like the opportunity to make a lot of
money here very quickly is right here
before so again there's this cliff
on the ground you can pick up or
whatever so you want to drive there very
fast but it's not in anyone's incentive
that we go over the cliff and it's not
like everybody's in their own car all
the cars are connected together with a
chain yeah so if anyone goes over
they'll start dragging others down the
other's down too and so ultimately it's
in the selfish
interests also of the people in the
companies to to uh
slow down when the when you start seeing
the Contours of the cliff there in front
of you right and the problem is that um
even though the people who are building
the technology
and the CEOs they really get it the
shareholders and these other Market
forces they are people who don't
honestly
understand that the cliff is there they
usually don't you have to get quite into
the weeds to really appreciate how
powerful this is and how fast and a lot
of people are even still stuck again in
this idea that
intelligent in this carbon chauvinism as
I like to call it that you can only have
our level of intelligence in
humans that there's something magical
about it whereas the people in the tech
companies
who build this stuff they all realize
that intelligence is information
processing of a certain kind and it
really doesn't matter at all whether the
information is processed by carbon atoms
in neurons in brains or by silicon atoms
and some technology we build